[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal d'information
locale elle nous sommes le lundi 14
février voici les titres la future aile
du marché de maurepas en concertation
auprès des locaux suite à l'incendié de
l'ancienne halle en 2019 sa remplaçante
est à l'étude habitants et mieux
commerçants et découvrir les plans ce
samedi le programme de rénovation
énergétique habiter mieux s'élargit
l'offre est complétée par save un
programme pour accompagner les yvelinois
dans leurs travaux focus sur ce
dispositif dans ce journal est un
évènement 100% jeu vidéo a pris place à
plaisir samedi plaisir gaming est dédié
au hit sport au programme tournoi
ateliers expositions de consoles vintage
retour sur cette première édition
est également dans ce journal retour sur
le déplacement de jean michel blanquer
ce vendredi à versailles yelle brive est
élu député de l'année également et puis
aujourd'hui c'est la saint valentin nous
sommes allés à la rencontre des évident
mois pour connaître leur programme
[Musique]
mais avant de débuter ce journal né en
1883 aurélien morin était ouvrier maçon
son épouse juliette morin né en 1887
étaient d'anciennes nourrissent de
l'assistante public le couple a été
reconnue à titre posthume juste parmi
les nations un titre décerné par
l'institut national pour la mémoire de
la shoah yad vashem c'était le 26 avril
2021 il honore les personnes qui ont
sauvé des juifs pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale les deux lits mayas ont
sauvé henry dauman ils ont accueilli le
petit garçon juif pendant deux ans comme
un membre à part entière à part entière
de leur famille une cérémonie était
organisée ce lundi à levallois-perret
dans les hauts-de-seine
[Musique]
et du côté de maurepas une nouvelle est
à l'étude pour le marché un projet de
reconstruction qui fait suite à
l'incendié de juillet 2019 une
concertation est menée auprès des locaux
les précisions dont ce reportage de
célia 400 go c'est une halle de marché
provisoire qui s'est installée place
riboud à mort par une implantation suite
à l'incendié de l'ancienne halle en 2019
sa remplaçante devrait voir le jour à
l'horizon 2024 un projet en concertation
depuis 2020 auprès des habitants des
commerçants et des élus samedi les morts
passe bien pouvez découvrir les plants
et l'architecturé de la future halle
aujourd'hui voilà on montre le concret
on pourra faire évidemment encore des
ajustements puisque la concertation avec
les mauraciens sert à ça et puis après
on lancera les marchés de travaux
franchement le design super beau tout
neuf vraiment ouais c'est vraiment pas
mal à un petit force à mettre un petit
peu de temps mais c'est pas mal j'ai vu
quand l'ancien à bollée c'était bien
dommage heureusement ils ont mis sens et
c'est très bien qu'il leur fasse et ça a
l'air assez moderne en plus donc c'est
très bien je le trouve assez
design quand même très épuré toute
embauche pense avec des matériaux
écologiques la nouvelle halle elle est
magnifique aussi je pense que nous
allons avoir beaucoup plus de clients si
l'ancienne halle et est ouverte avec des
étals amovible le nouvel espace de 1500
mètres carrés devraient accueillir 20
étals fixes destinées aux commerçants
alimentaires des étals qui soient
pérennes une nouvelle ferme et plus
sécurisé avec des toilettes publiques
également ceux qui me demandent aussi de
mort passe bien la nouvelle halle sera
tournée vers le développement durable on
aura des panneaux photovoltaïques sur le
toit pour nous permettre d'avoir une
énergie propre on va pouvoir avoir un
bac aussi de récupération d'eau de pluie
pour pouvoir faire l'arrosage de nos
espaces verts et donc on pense le projet
à long terme le projet a nécessité 18
mois de travaux livraison prévue début
2011 24
et vous pourrez découvrir d'autres
marchés yvelinois dans nos éditions à
venir notre dossier de la semaine y est
consacré nous vous emmènerons au coeur
du marché de mantes-la-jolie de
rambouillet ou encore à 2 versailles ce
sera à retrouver est dès demain dans
notre journal
et au centre commercial westfield vélizy
2 c'est une journée de sensibilisation
au handicap qui a pris place samedi un
événement organisé en faveur de
l'inclusion les associations partenaires
du comité d'inclusion sociale du centre
est est au rendez vous comme la paix est
france handicap l'association valentin
haüy ou encore du bruit dans ma vie au
programme rencontre avec ces
associations ou encore performance
artistique les clients du centre étaient
également invités à participer à des
ateliers de mise en situation initiation
par exemple obhrai parcours en fauteuil
roulant ou encore café dans le noir est
bien l'objectif pour le centre
commercial c'était de sensibiliser ses
visiteurs pour mieux comprendre et mieux
appréhender les handicaps physiques ou
psychiques
[Musique]
et le vendredi à 28 janvier dernier le
conseil départemental des yvelines a
voté en séance le déploiement du
programme sarr donc service
d'accompagnement à la rénovation
énergétique
cette mesure vient compléter le
dispositif départemental déjà en place
sur le territoire habiter mieux et pour
parler à de cette thématique de ce sujet
nous recevons en plateau une grille
bobillier bonsoir m'en sors donc ingrid
vous êtes chef de mission en charge
justement de l'habitat privé au conseil
départemental des yvelines et nous
recevons également grégory canal est
journaliste pour tv 78 bon soir sur le
sud parmi les dispositifs en place il ya
le programme donc habiter mieux on y
reviendra avec vous un grégory canale et
on commence à présent avec vous une red
bull y est depuis dix ans le département
des yvelines donc a décidé de s'engager
sur la thématique de la rénovation
énergétique pourquoi sa thématique alors
effectivement aujourd'hui la halle à
l'éradication des passeurs énergétique
est devenue une véritable problématique
un enjeu majeur face à l'urgence
climatique
mais le département effectivement comme
vous l'avez dit n'a pas attendu que cela
devienne une véritable urgence absolue
on va dire aujourd'hui pour s'engager
dans la lutte contre la précarité
énergétique donc ça fait effectivement
depuis 2011 exactement quel département
des yvelines est engagé dans la lutte
contre la précarité énergétique à
travers le déploiement du programme sar
c'était une volonté très forte de
pouvoir permettre aux habitants aux
notamment aux yvelinois de pouvoir
réaliser des travaux de rénovation
énergétique en toute sérénité et en
toute confiance mais bon quand on
reviendra au programme save dans un
instant et juste avant qu'il ya 11
millions de français qui occupent
aujourd'hui des logements qualifié de
passoires thermiques la rénovation
énergétique c'est donc une bonne
solution pour être mieux chauffée faire
baisser la facture d'énergie pourtant
peu de personnes franchissent le pas
souvent démunis face au montant des
travaux et donc aux dispositifs
existants et grégory canal et donc
journalistes pour tv 60,18 je le disais
vous êtes avec nous dans les yvelines
habiter mieux donc peut aider à y voir
plus clair c'est quoi concrètement c'est
un programme d' aides à la rénovation
nick porté par le département des
yvelines est aussi par la nana c'est un
cible pour dire agence nationale de
l'habitat l'objectif c'est de
conseillers tout au long de l'année les
yvelinois dans leurs projets de
rénovation et ce à chaque étape cet
accompagnement est gratuit habiter mieux
aide également dans les financements des
travaux et 3400 propriétaire yves lennon
ont déjà été épaulé par ce dispositif et
commence à se traduire concrètement cet
accompagnement alors je vous disais déjà
cet accompagnement est gratuit un
opérateur doit vous aider à y voir plus
clair dans les travaux à privilégier la
vérification des devis et aussi vous
assister dans les démarches
administratives qui ont ces peuvent être
parfois lourdes habité lieu peut vous
fournir également un diagnostic
thermique pour les maisons individuelles
et surtout vous donner accès à des aides
majorées elles peuvent aller tout de
même jusqu'à 75% du montant total des
travaux de rénovation et donc c'est un
point sur qui peut en bénéficier
déjà deux conditions les travaux ne
doivent pas avoir commencé doivent
améliorer au moins 35 % de la
performance énergétique du logement
habiter mieux s'adresse aux
propriétaires occupants sous condition
de ressources les travaux elles doivent
concerner leur résidence principale
datant de plus de 15 ans cela s'adresse
aussi aux bailleurs sous conditions de
loyer pour savoir si on est éligible
rendez vous sur le site de l' agence
nationale de l'habitat qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran merci beaucoup de
galeries canale pour ces précisions
ingrid abus liés quel bilan vous faites
de cette mesure alors le bilan du
programme habiter mieux trouve que ce
programme a fait ses preuves notamment
puisque comme l'a dit monsieur 3400
ménages aujourd'hui ont pu en bénéficier
cela représente quand même 24 millions
d'euros dead qui ont pu être octroyés à
ces ménages yvelinois et générant plus
de 40 millions d'euros de travaux donc
ça aussi un impact sur le parc privé de
manière générale la rénovation du parc
privé ce qui correspond aussi à ce qu'on
appelle la valeur verte c'est à dire que
c'est aussi un moyen pour le territoire
de rome plus performant et donc plus
rentable et plus attractifs sont son
parc privé donc globalement le bilan du
programme habiter mieux est très positif
en plus vous parlez de 3400 ménages
s'est depuis le nouveau programme
habiter mieux mais c'est presque ont
atteint presque 5000 ménages accompagné
au jeu devis dans le cadre de ses
programmes voilà donc on a notre bilan
est plutôt très positif malgré la crise
sanitaire de l'année 2020 qui a quand
même marqué un coup d'arrêt notamment
puisque certaines visites ne pouvait
plus faire à domicile etc mais donc le
bilan est plutôt positif
bilan positif donc on va revenir sur le
programme save dont on parlait tout à
l'heure service d'accompagnement à la
rénovation énergétique il vient
compléter
finalement ce dispositif
concrètement qu'est ce qu'il apporte de
plus par rapport à habiter mieux alors
tout simplement ce que ce qu'on a dit
aussi dans le cadre du programme habiter
mieux c'est un problème qui est
aujourd'hui à destination d'une certaine
partie de la population serrer les
coudes il est conditionné à certains
niveaux de ressources or le département
des yvelines a identifié très rapidement
a pris conscience très rapidement qu'une
un des freins principal une des
principales difficultés rencontrées pour
les mettre par les ménages pour réaliser
pour se lancer dans les travaux de
rénovation énergétique c'est justement
cette crainte cette difficulté de se
repérer dans cet écosystème de la
rénovation énergétique qui est
particulièrement complexe parce que
beaucoup le beaucoup d'être beaucoup de
dispositions existantes et des deux
partenaires d'acteurs de dispositifs de
programmes la pr et même des entreprises
peu scrupuleuses
donc aujourd'hui on s'est rendu compte
que c'était vraiment un d un effet
levier vraiment principal c'est
d'accompagner l'ensemble des ménages et
c'est dans ce cadre là qu'il département
des yvelines a souhaité déployer sur son
territoire le programme ça donc le
service d'accompagnement à la rénovation
énergétique depuis le 28 janvier comme
vous l'avez précisé qui va permettre
d'élargir
cet accompagnement qui pour l'instant
est essoufflé une certaine partie de la
population à l'ensemble des habitants et
à l'ensemble des yvelinois qui
souhaitent se lancer dans leurs travaux
de rénovation énergétique donc justement
si je souhaite finalement faire
rénovation énergétique et je souhaite
justement à voir ce programme ça
recommence je dois m'y prendre alors
c'est assez simple et je vous invite à
consulter le site internet de vw w
yveline point fr sur lequel vous aurez
tout affiches sur lesquelles vous aurez
toutes les informations et vous pourrez
prendre contact avec les différents
opérateurs parce qu'un point important
aussi qui a permis à notre programme
habiter mieux de bien fonctionner sur
les yvelines c'est que le département
des yvelines a souhaité mandaté des
experts des tiers de confiance qui
apporte cet accompagnement gratuit aux
ménages donc aujourd'hui vous pouvez
vous lancer j'ai envie de dire les yeux
fermés puisque de toute façon vous serez
accompagnés par des experts des tiers de
confiance qu'ils sont mandatés par le
département d évident donc lancé vous en
toute sérénité et en toute confiance
d'ailleurs je le précise c'est bien
divine point fr que c'était healing
points ce qui est affiché juste pour ses
vieilles téléspectateurs sur sur le bon
site en arrière si pour cette précision
grégory canale et merci à vous a une
grande idée d'avoir été avec nous je le
rappelle vous êtes chef de mission en
charge de l'habitat privé au conseil
départemental à des yvelines
[Musique]
et comme chaque année les prix du
trombinoscope récompense les
personnalités politiques de l'année pour
la 30e édition la cérémonie s'est tenue
ce jeudi à 10 février à l'assemblée
nationale 2 yvelinoise ont été couronnés
ya lebron privé nommé député de l'année
est valérie pécresse personnalité
politique de l'année 2021 le récit de la
soirée avec nicolas landry
elle fait la fierté de ses enfants et de
son mari une fierté d'autant plus forte
ce jeudi 10 février 2022 il y avait le
brunch iv vient de recevoir le prix de
députés de l'année 2021 une
reconnaissance célébrer en famille la
famille ça vous permet aussi de rester
très ancré dans la réalité
et quand vous rentrez et avait après une
dure journée que vous frimer avec ce qui
s'est passé souvent mes enfants me
rappel à l'ordre parce que ils ont
d'autres préoccupations
j'ai repris les médecins les courses
les dossiers scolaires mais avec plaisir
présidente de la commission des lois à
l'assemblée nationale avocate et juriste
de profession gilles brunn qui vivait
s'est engagée derrière emmanuel macron
en 2010 est une femme politique issu de
la société civile un parcours récompensé
par le jury du trombinoscope
c'est quelqu'un qui arrive et de la
société civile qui étaient complètement
inconnus on va le dire au bataillon
finalement qui a fait son trou qui a
à force de pugnacité s'est imposé la
sphère politique yvelinoise était à
l'honneur lors de cette 30ème cérémonie
du trombinoscope à côté de yaël brawn
pie v valérie pécresse a obtenu le prix
de personnalité politique de l'année
2021 c'est une première marche vers
personnalité de l'année 2022 en tout cas
c'est ce que j'espère j'espère que les
français poursuivront ils me feront
confiance
cette nomination est une reconnaissance
de ses victoires politiques obtenus en
2021 d'abord aux élections régionales
d'île de france puis à la primaire
interne des républicains restent un défi
de taille en 2022 remporté l'élection
présidentielle en avril prochain
et durant trois jours le tout nouveau
campus de versailles ouvrait les portes
de la grande écurie du roi aux jeunes un
forum des métiers dédié entièrement au
métier formation du patrimoine et de
l'artisanat d'excellence alors que le
projet prend peu à peu forme le ministre
de l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer elle s'est rendue sur place
c'était ce vendredi le reportage de
grégory quelle année canal et mélanie
poké patrie jacques de dix semaines
le ministre était déjà venu en 2019 pour
lancer les jalons du projet créé à
versailles un campus d'excellence pour
les métiers du patrimoine et de
l'artisanat trois ans plus tard jean
michel blanquer air était de retour pour
se rendre compte des évolutions du
dossier une idée née à la suite de
l'incendié de notre dame de paris dans
une france en perte de ses savoir-faire
ancestraux c'est une idée généreuse
parce qu'elle consiste à partir d'une
richesse à partir d'un patrimoine que
l'on a pour aller vers la création de
l'avenir c'est à dire la transmission de
savoir faire à notre jeunesse fait de
traditions mais aussi de modernité
notamment avec les usages numériques qui
permettent de faire tant de choses quoi
comme on le voit là pour la diversité
des métiers impliqués dans un tel campus
l'objectif à présent pour le campus de
versailles a tiré ses élèves un forum
des métiers formations du patrimoine et
de l'artisanat d'excellence s'est tenu
du 10 au 12 février à la grande écurie
du roi du château de versailles pour
faire venir des jeunes à versailles ici
des jeunes qui sont pas forcément
familier du patrimoine de la culture de
l'artisanat et qui peut être vont faire
leur destin leur réussite sur place les
collégiens lycéens et étudiants ont pu
découvrir aussi la grande diversité des
métiers au travers de cinq filles
proposé par le campus de versailles et
les possibilités sont immenses près de
300 profession comme débouchés sont des
métiers extrêmement épanouissant c'est
vraiment un ascenseur au sein de sa
soeur sociale qui ouvre vraiment les
wags de l'épanouissement de la
révélation on travaille tous dans la
même lignée ligne d'apprendre de bons
jeunes à trouver une formation leur voix
et puis parler avec eux de passion ce
lieu de nous retrouver ensemble c'est
vraiment un plus ça et c'est très
agréable
après deux ans d'action en les murs le
campus de versailles est entré dans une
phase d'expérimentation depuis l'automne
il sera totalement opérationnel en 2025
un site de 6000 mètres carrés dans la
grande écurie du roi du château de
versailles
un peu d'autres sujets à présent je vous
le disais en début de journée nous
sommes le 14 février c'est donc une
journée spéciale notamment pour les
amoureux ou pas à cette occasion à nous
sommes allés à la rencontre des
yvelinois pour connaître leur programme
c'était au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude de regarder j'ai offert un
cadeau ce matin mon conjoint par contre
au niveau une sortie restaurant on ne
fait pas le jour même parce que c'est
vrai que c'est toujours le lundi on va y
aller plutôt à la vendredi j'ai même pas
pu de tamis du coup c'est compliqué mais
sinon bah non rien de prévu du tout
ci-après ya des offres sur le restaurant
city stars de quettehou j'ai acheté des
roses pour ma femme c'est quand même
normal et puis
c'est bien et puis c'est la marque le
coup quoi pour moi c'est pas commercial
c'est mai c'est la fête un peu c'est la
fête de la femme passe bas rien de prévu
un franchement personne en vue du coup
jusqu'à 15 heures et après je rejoins ma
copine on passe un peu de temps ensemble
je les prie une écharpe parce que l
avait vu être et sa belle fenêtre le
maître du coup je me suis moi pourquoi
pas les prendre
on n'est pas au courant donc c'est
encore mieux et fait une rose à côté de
ça quand même
et des messages seront d'ailleurs à
découvrir enfin d'édition de l'ispor à
plaisir maintenant ce samedi à 12
février la commune organisé son premier
plaisir gaming la compétition a
rassemblé 120 jeunes elles se sont
affrontées sur quatre jeux différents
nous sommes partis suivre l'un d'eux un
reportage de céline gars de 100 go et
bixente mais rien senti steban
nous sommes en milieu d'après-midi et
adam a déjà remporté plusieurs matches
de son jeu de prédilection super smash
bros ultimate
victoire donc j'ai ma place en grande
finale c'est le tout dernier le tout
dernier match que je dois jouer pour
gagner ce tournoi donc je m'attendais
pas du tout à arriver jusque là arrivé
tôt ce matin à cette première édition du
plaisir gaming le jeune joueur habitué
des compétitions n'est pas venu seul
depuis le collège dix ans qu'on se
connaît maintenant moi je viens de
perdre 3 pluie donc je me retrouve en
looser squatteurs c'est à dire que pour
gagner le tournoi maintenant il me faut
remporter est un excellent d'affilée ça
risque de pas être évident mais
en attendant leur prochain match les
deux amis s'entraîne dans le palais des
sports pierre de coubertin mise à
disposition pour l'événement ça m'a
beaucoup plu de venir ici on va dire
qu'après un an et demi de compétitif
considère ce tournoi comme étant l'un
des meilleurs en terme de qualité auquel
j'ai joué pourtant j'en ai fait beaucoup
c'est quelque chose qui est dans l'air
du temps et qu'on voulait proposer à nos
jeunes de plaisir et des environs
puisqu'en fait on a ratissé un peu plus
large on a voulu que ce soit un
événement familial puisque on appris que
des jeux donc avec un âge minimum entre
3 et 12 ans un d'or de ce monde gamer be
love qui a finalement remporté sa finale
et s'est vu décerner un trophée et une
figurine au total 120 joueurs se sont
affrontés de 10h à 22h sur quatre jeux
super smash bros ultimate fifa 2022
league of legends et roccat league
elle avait participé à the voice quitte
en 2019 ce samedi nour a fait son grand
retour dans l'émission adultes cette
fois ci avant sa première participation
la jeune eurasienne n'avait jamais pris
de cours de chant à tout juste 16 ans
est la plus jeune candidate du concours
elle samedi lors des auditions à
l'aveuglé l'a fait se retourner les
quatre coaches sur une reprise du titre
tous les cris les sos de balavoine et
c'est l'équipe de florent pagny qu'elle
a choisi de rejoindre pour poursuivre
l'aventuré
prochaine étape pour nourrir les battles
et c'est la fin de ce journal à merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi dans un instant
retrouver michael et demi d'euros pour
la présentation de votre magazine
sportif il sera comme chaque lundi
panier de 10 mt mais rien senti steban
pour vos résultats du week end je vous
souhaite à toutes et tous une très bonne
soit saint valentin que vous soyez en
couple ou célibataire et bien sûr bonne
fête aux valentin également on se quitte
sur vos messages à très vite sur tv 78
beldame
intelligente cherche le chef a donc déjà
seulement 1 valentin et jolie valentine
de bon coeur et gasmi zhu hongjie je
t'aime maman je t'aime et à je t'aime
beaucoup et merci pour ton aide pour des
efforts avec moi parce que
j'ai passé par des moments difficiles et
il était toujours là avec moi je t'aime
beaucoup et je te remercie voilà
[Musique]